so Brady here's the classic periodic
table of elements and you've made an
entire series of videos about these
things so this is the chemists view of
the periodic table
some astronomer they've got a slightly
different view of what a periodic table
looks like there's no stronger versions
we've got hydrogen helium and everything
else we lump together and we call metals
now there's a number reason for doing
this firstly obviously it will wind up
chemists which is Jeff definitely a
bonus but there's actually there's no
there are two important reasons for this
we think hydrogen and helium are
basically primordial they were cooked up
in the first 20 minutes of the Big Bang
so the vast majority of the hydrogen
helium that we see was produced in the
very very early stage of my universe
whereas the methyls and chemists will
hate us for calling oxygen and nitrogen
metal but everything else that we call
metals were actually cooked up in stars
or and the heavier elements heavier than
iron were cooked up in supernova
explosions when stars die so these are
all produced by Astrophysical processes
whereas most of the hydrogen helium was
produced in the Big Bang and in fact we
have a term we call metallicity
basically how much of this stuff there
is relative to hydrogen and formally
it's defined as basically the relative
amounts of iron to hydrogen ion plays a
quite key role in this whole process and
the relative amounts of iron to hydrogen
tells it they say how many generations
of stars we've had in the galaxy so this
shockwave from the supernova spreads out
at velocities of tens of thousands of
clothes per second
you